[Musique]
tu pars ou du coup au crotoy eva ça fait
rêver les vacances de poids de l'âge
philippe et ses parents ce genre
adorable c'est important pour moi que ça
se passe bien c'est pas de chance
[Musique]
papa tu joues c'est à toi maman niveau
c'est un deal avec 1006 réussi son bac
c'est lui qui choisi la destination des
vacances pour ce le moment suffisamment
bas tu vas t'éclater est bizarre on va
choisi bizarre tu sais [ __ ] dans cette
île de jane
wihr store vraiment heureuse td cycling
cette musique qui infecte
moi j'ai pas choisi d'y aller avec shrek
shrek maman il est ringard nom se fait
dans d'autres séries avec francky c'est
drôle parce qu'on se connaît d'elle il
ya très très longtemps il va jamais
regretté cette période sommes bien moi
c'est fini
s il sait l'homme et là je raconte ici
les mains
[Musique]
qui sait ce qu'il dit caballero
non mais attendez charolles or on vient
encore de me proposer du haj klouf
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il
en attendant regardez maintenant
[Musique]